Limbs is on the stage. All right. So,
how would you how would you deal with uh
with this? Is this on YouTube? Is this a
YouTube video as well?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I
>> YouTube. What's going on YouTube?
>> They're saying hi.
>> Free Palestine.
>> Free Palestine. Listen. So, I I I'd say
uh Paul didn't corrupt uh the message.
Uh but he gave it a good go. He tried
to. Let me let me um let me elaborate.
what I what I think your argument is
going to be is that obviously um
the Quran the Quran is is seen as a
guardian over over the message and and
etc. Um so you're going to say if if it
was being protected and supposed to be
preserved then why why could it be
corrupted? So I wouldn't say I wouldn't
say I wouldn't say I wouldn't say that
it's uh
>> that's not what I'm concerned with at
all.
>> Okay. So I wouldn't say I wouldn't say
that it's um the the like God's message
was actually corrupted but what Paul did
is he added to it and
>> so from Allah
>> what message what message did he try to
corrupt or did he add to? What was that
message?
>> So so for instance there was uh well
Jesus said to follow all of what the
Pharisees teach and nothing at what they
do. Um and then Paul said that um you
you you can you can eat anything. Um
etc. So that's just one example.
>> Got you. So So wait, so specifically,
let's let's do this one at a time. So
specifically the message that Paul tried
to corrupt, we can find it in what
Matthew wrote.
>> Say that again. So the message that you
said that Paul tried to corrupt and add
to, we can find that message of Jesus in
Matthew's writing.
>> So So the the the general way of way of
looking at this is if something uh if
you can cross reference it with the
Quran and the Quran agrees, then we know
that it's from Allah, right?
>> Okay. So
>> So the so the Quran agrees to do
everything the Pharisees say.
>> Listen, no, I didn't say that. Oh,
>> I didn't I didn't say that.
>> Oh, that cuz that's what that's what you
that's what you quoted. So,
>> that's what you said. That's what you
said, Mr. Logic.
>> That's not what I said.
>> You said that.
>> I didn't.
>> So, look, for example, I asked you what
is the message that Paul tried to
corrupt and add to. The first thing you
did was quote Matthew 23 where Jesus
says to listen to all the Pharisees,
what all the Pharisees say, just not
what they do. Um, and then you alluded
to And then you alluded to Hold on, hold
on a second. And then you alluded to
that being, you know, teaching the law
and stuff. So I'm asking you, so when
you when you give me that answer, that
implies that you're saying that the
message of Jesus can be found in what
Matthew wrote. So is that correct?
>> The me the message that that Jesus as in
within Matthew there there'll be some
truths of what Jesus taught. Is that
what you're asking?
>> No, I'm asking is the message of Jesus
in what Matthew wrote? Because that's
where you went.
>> Yeah. So there there are there are
obviously truths in in the Bible.
>> Not if there's not if there's truth. So
my my question isn't are there truths in
the Bible? Are there not? That's not my
question. My question is very very
clear. Is the message of Jesus found in
what Matthew wrote?
>> Yeah, it can be. Yeah.
>> And one example of what Jesus taught the
message of Jesus is in Matthew 23 where
he mentions to listen to what the
Pharisees say, not as they do. Correct.
>> No. It says it says uh do everything
they say.
>> So is that so so that so that's a
teaching that's part of the message of
Jesus. Is that correct?
>> That's a teaching. So just just to be
clear um Paul Paul isn't in the Quran.
This is an internal critique of the of
the Bible. Just to let you know. So you
can't conflate the two here.
>> If we're doing an internal critique of
the Bible, right?
>> It's not an internal critique of the
Bible.
>> Okay. So is Paul found anywhere else
other than the Bible? Yeah, he's found
in your Islamic scholars in their
sources. Yeah, he's found he's found in
a nashak.
>> So where where is he where is he uh like
an authority in in the Quran?
>> The according to Ibnak, it says that
Paul is a messenger that Jesus sent
along with the other disciples.
>> Who who said that? He said that he said
that Paul's a messenger of of Jesus of
God. Of Jesus.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Of God. You got it right.
>> A messenger of Jesus.
>> Yep.
>> And he's a Muslim.
>> Yeah. It' been a shock. You never heard
of him? That that sounds that sounds a
bit kufar to me. I don't I don't know
how uh how uh a man can be a messenger
of a man.
>> Well, if a man sends people with his
message, they're his messengers, right?
>> Well, no. I I don't believe that. You'd
have to you'd have to get me that that
um evidence. You're saying he's a he's a
he's a Muslim scholar. You said
>> I Yes, I wrote the earliest biography on
Muhammad's life, the life of the
prophet, the life of Prophet Muhammad.
>> Well, well, I can flat out say that. Uh
that sounds that sounds very Shia to me.
>> He's a Sunni. A man.
>> He's a Sunni.
>> A a man a man a man can't be a messenger
of a man. That's as well as uh Jesus was
uh not not on earth when Paul said that
he saw him. Right. Well, that's
according to the biblical standard, but
according to what Ibn Ashak says and
demonstrates is that Paul, and he's quot
he's he's apparently quoting Muhammad,
by the way,
>> but that Paul is a messenger of Jesus
that Jesus sent. He's one of the people
Jesus sent out to spread his message.
>> Nah, no, I don't I don't I don't hold to
that. I don't know what I don't know
where you've got that from. I don't
>> I got it from the earliest source on
Muhammad's life, which is Ibnashak.
Ibnak's biography of the of the prophet.
>> I don't have to I don't know. I don't
believe that. You have to show me that,
mate.
>> I will. I'll show you it. In the
meantime, in the meantime, in regards to
Jesus's message, when you you quoted,
you quoted me. Oh, I I know. I'm I'm
going to show you that in a second. I I
promise you I'm going to show you in a
second. But the first I want to make
sure we solidify the first point that
when you quoted Matthew 23 when I asked
you what is the message of Jesus and you
quoted Matthew 23 where Jesus says do
everything I'm sorry uh do everything
that the uh the Pharisees say but don't
do as they do that that is part of the
message of Jesus. Is that correct
>> according according to the Bible? Yeah.
if we're doing an internal critique.
>> We're doing I'll ask I'll ask it again,
brother, because it sounds like you're
backtracking on your words again because
I asked you what is the message that
Paul tried to add to or corrupt and you
quoted Matthew 23.
>> So that leads me to believe that you
believe that you're pointing to that
>> as part of Jesus's message. Correct.
>> According to the Bible, if we're doing
an internal
>> Is that Is that correct though? Is that
Jesus's message?
>> So according to the Bible, yes, it is
Jesus's message.
>> Okay. So is that objective or like is
that the a fact? Is the Bible correct
when it's saying that this is part of
Jesus's message?
>> So So what what I'm saying is you're
you're asking what message did Paul
corrupt? Right.
>> Yes.
>> And what I'm what I'm answering is
there's teachings within the Bible that
uh Jesus said according to the Bible and
then Paul goes against that. Are those
are those are those Jesus's actual
teachings?
>> Okay. So, yes, we're doing an internal
critique according to the Bible.
>> So, yes, those are Jesus's actual
teachings. So, you believe that Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John contain the actual
real teachings of Jesus, right?
>> I I I I think you're I think you're
trying to um straw man my position on
>> straw man or or repeat your words. All
I'm doing is repeating.
>> I clearly Okay. Did I say according to
the Bible or did I say that's what I
believe?
>> Well, yeah. You said, "Yeah, you believe
that according to the Bible." So you're
saying the Bible actually contains his
message.
>> I believe according to the Bible.
According to the Bible, Jesus
>> So Jesus's message is in the Bible,
right?
>> Of course. Obviously.
>> So you notice you said that again. Now
I'm going to have to probably remind
this because you said just now again
that the Bible obviously. You said
obviously, of course, obviously the
Bible contains the message of Jesus.
That's what you just said. So don't
backtrack on that later. So since the
Bible has Jesus's message, then we look
at what Jesus taught in the Bible, we
taugh we see that Jesus taught that he's
the son of God. We see that he taught
that he's supposed to be crucified and
that he's supposed to suffer and rise
again on the third day. So that's the
message of Jesus that we find in the
Bible, right?
>> So So nah, no, no, no. You can't say the
whole Bible does that.
>> So you just said,
>> "Oh man, I'm I'm getting lost, man. I'm
I'm honestly getting I'm I'm getting
lost. So, I don't know what I don't know
what your position is.
>> All right, let me let me let me let me
explain. Yeah, so some of the Bible uh I
think it's like the what's it? The
synoptic gospels or whatever they're
called, right? They uh depict Jesus as a
messenger of God, a prophet, someone who
believed in one God, montheist. And then
there's there's other other books uh
that Paul wrote that um have very high
christologology. I think also John as
well.
>> Can I read you something? Can I can I
read you something from the synoptics?
And um and what what what I'm saying I
wish you'd let me land my point. Maybe
you'd understand what I'm saying.
>> I understand what you're saying. You're
you're backtracking.
>> And basically the teach the teachings of
Jesus that are found in the earliest
gospels
>> like Matthew and Mark and Luke Paul goes
against those things.
>> Okay.
>> So for instance like I'll give you
>> hold on hold on no hold on. I wanted to
read something from the synoptics as
you're appealing to the synoptics.
>> Like Jesus being sent to the
>> a limbs limbs limbs. Hello limbs. Don't
go in bot mode. You know you interrupt.
>> Don't go in robot mode. Don't go in
robot mode. I want to I want to quote
you something from the synoptic gospels.
>> Here it is. This is what Jesus says in
the synoptics. This is Matthew 11. This
is verse number 27. He says, "All things
have been handed over to me by my
father, and no one knows the son except
the father. And no one knows the father
except the son and anyone to whom the
son chooses to reveal him. Does that
sound like low or highristologology to
you?
>> Low christologology.
>> All right. So it's lowristologology for
Jesus to say that everything that the
father owns he owns as well. That's
lowristologology.
>> Yeah. So it the the problem that you
have here is that it was given to him.
Now, can the can the most high God have
any authority given to him?
>> Yes. Yes. If he humbles himself. Now,
now you're not answering the question,
Limbs.
>> Hold on. Hold on.
>> You're not answering the question,
Limbs.
>> Listen, I am answering. I'm answering
directly. You said, you said, is it high
christologology or lowristologology?
It's literally very lowristologology,
right?
>> Okay. So, so B, so basically a creature.
So it's low christologology to believe
that somebody else other than the father
owns all things. Everything that's in
existence he owns.
>> So So if you read the verse again, it
says
>> all things have been handed over to me
by my father. So does the son own
everything the father owns according to
this?
>> So the question is you're saying Jesus
is God, right?
>> Does the son own everything the father
owns according to this?
>> According to this, he owns everything.
Uh but it was given to him. No worries.
So everything, the universe, all of
creation, prophets, demons, everyone,
everything belongs to the son the same
way it belongs to the father, right?
>> No, not the same way.
>> Really? So it says, "All things have
been handed over to me by my father." So
does Jesus also own all things?
>> No, but you the problem is you said he
owns He owns
>> Does Jesus also own all things like the
father?
>> Hey, hey, logic logic. Let me answer.
>> Straight. All right. How about straight
answer?
>> How about let me answer.
>> Straight answer then.
>> How about how about let me answer.
>> Go ahead. Don't waffle.
>> So he he owns he owns all things but not
in the same way as the father.
>> Okay.
>> Because so if you own all things if the
father owns all things and the son owns
all things. Oh, but he doesn't own it
just like the father own. What are you
talking about?
>> No.
>> How good can you be?
>> Logic.
>> You're too dishonest. What is this
>> logic? If you let me finish, you would
have understood my my point, mate. All
right. But you you jumped in, didn't
you?
>> Do do you believe that a creature can
own everything Allah owns?
>> No. No. No. No.
>> So would this be would this be
blasphemy?
>> This would this would be this would be
uh this is in the Bible. And yeah, it is
blasphemy. Yeah.
>> Why is it blasphemy?
>> Because you're you're saying that you're
basically uh saying there's a partner
with God. So
>> So according to the synoptic gospels,
Jesus is a partner, makes himself a
partner with the father.
>> Yeah.
>> Is that low or high christologology?
>> So it's low christologology. The reason
being so if you if you let me finish and
I think you get my the thing is logic I
think you actually get my point you're
you're you're purposely you're purposely
cutting in right at the end where I'm
saying my point right so yes according
to this he owns all things but the
problem is he was given it by something
else you know Paul says the same thing
>> answer this question now answer this
question answer this question
>> is is the father is the father given
authority
>> you need to answer is The father gi an
authority by answer this. Yeah. So the
answer to that is no because the father
is not the one who humbles himself. The
son humbled himself. So because the son
set aside his divine privileges for a
time and humbled himself, he can then be
exalted back to that status when he's
done with his mission or so on and so
forth. So that is why Jesus can say that
all things have been handed over to me
by my father because he's humbled
himself. He came down and then is being
elevated back up.
However, this is the issue with you,
Limbs. According to According to you,
That's exactly what it says. That's
exactly what it says.
>> So, according to you, Hold on, Limbs.
Now you're cutting me off. According to
you, Limbs, Jesus making himself a
partner with the father is blasphemous.
However, it's low christologology. I I
don't understand how there can be
blasphemy christologology.
>> Christology is the study of Christ. the
study of Christ in this person. So, so
you can you can either you can either
have a high view of Christ, meaning that
he's equal with the father or a partner
with the father or divine in some way,
or you can have a low view of Christ, or
you can have a low view of Christ where
he's just a mere good prophet, a mere
man. So, which is this teaching? Is this
teaching that Jesus is just a mere man,
a mere son? I'm sorry, a mere man, a
mere prophet, mere messenger of God, or
is he a partner with the Which one is it
teaching?
>> I I I would say I would say it's I would
say it's neither high or low. And I know
I said it.
>> You said it's neither high or low,
>> but um but I didn't I did in in all
honesty uh logic, right? When you
defined it, then you taught me something
then. Low christologology means that
he's a mere man. You're saying?
>> Yeah. Locristologology is that he's not
divine. It's that he is just a he's just
a mere messenger.
>> He's just a mere messenger. Right. So I
I wouldn't say I wouldn't say it's is as
low as it could be, but I wouldn't say
it's I definitely wouldn't say it's
high. The reason being is because your
definition of it being high was that
he's equal to the father. And if he's
equal to the father, right, then nothing
has to be given to him cuz he's already
got it, right? He's the highest
authority. Doesn't need anything given
to him. Okay? Right? Just like the
father, he didn't have anything given.
>> You you agree that this you agree this
is blasphemous, right? Limbs,
>> you you inserted that um he humbled
himself and he was being brought back.
>> Limbs, you you agree that this is
blasphemous, right? As you last time,
you agree this was blasphemous.
>> What?
>> You said what?
>> What? What's blasphemous? As in him him
having him owning everything?
>> Yeah. Is this blasphemous?
>> But when you say him owning everything,
you mean he owns the profits? As in he's
been given like All things, bro. Is that
is that difficult to to know to
understand?
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's that's um that goes
that goes against uh that goes against
everything I believe. Yeah.
>> Exactly. So going against everything you
believe. However, this is where you said
I can find the message of Jesus in the
synoptic gospels in Matthew. Especially
earlier you said and you you know this
is before we start the stream but
earlier you said in specifically the Q
gospel the theoretical gospel that says
that Matthew and Mark's sayings of Jesus
that they record that Mark doesn't that
is the Q gospel and that's the message
of Jesus that's the so according to what
you say
>> I didn't say it was the I didn't say it
was the verbatim message Jesus I said it
was the the closest thing to it was
>> take care of you you're you're a liar
you're absolute liar I can't do If
you're going to lie, like you can't have
a conversation with a liar. If you're
going to continue to just lie on what
you say, we can't talk. Take care of
yourself, man. Goodness gracious. Right
in the beginning of this live, you
literally said the you're going to say
the NGO is Q Source. That's what you
said. And then I had to explain to you
what Q source was. And you was like,
"Okay, yeah, that's right. That's
right." Now you're lying. Now you're
saying you never said that. Like, get
out of here, bro. Get get out of your
limbs.